hi everyone my name is Tamara chambers
and this is Tamara Jessa and tonight I
saw the happy time murders right yep
nailed it so usually these episodes are
10 minutes I think that's like over a
nice time to have for your video and
that's what I usually aim for I don't
know if I'm gonna have 10 minutes worth
of content to talk about because this
movie was honestly it's okay
I was at Wizard World today so I have
pretend on a wasp
I had my wasp helmet I ran now it was
time to make an actual wasp costume so I
went to Wizard World I walked over to
see this film and I was feeling pretty
optimistic about it it looked fun and
raunchy what could go wrong though I did
see the trailer where they have just a
very long and drawn-out orgasm joke
which spoilers I guess didn't I was
going into it hoping that it was gonna
be funny though I really enjoy Melissa
McCarthy I do understand why people
don't enjoy her she got so popular so
fast and then she was in just so much
think people got like a little worn out
of her I think she's really funny I
thought the cast was was killers Stanley
from the office
hell yes Danny I love Stanley I just
watched my first ever Muppets film I
watched the original The Muppets movie
for Tamara's never seen I had a great
time with it
I thought the comedy and that was miles
better than the comedy was in this it
was just it was awkward and honestly
they did a pretty good job with
character building like I cared about
the romantic elements of this film I
want to be Melissa McCarthy's friends
and I also just left feeling super
disappointed with the comedy of this
film story-wise it was fine but the
script lacked a lot in the dialogue and
it lacked a lot in the comedy it didn't
feel
get hit at the end of the film they show
like the process of filming with it
which is vastly so interesting to see
how the the Muppets were films and and
maneuvered through and puppeteered and
that was so much more interesting and
funny than the films like some of the
outtakes in the bloopers they had were
so much funnier
the story is that Muppets are
discriminated against they live amongst
humans and the first Muppet to ever be
allowed to be a cop who was also the
last Muppet to ever be allowed to be a
cop now he's a private eye he is our
lead character playing against Melissa
McCarthy there's some conflicts between
him and Melissa McCarthy as they used to
be partners and now they're clearly not
and kind of a rekindling a friendship
there there's some cute romance Maya
Rudolph plays this character named
bubbles who was my favorite character I
thought that she was hilarious
definitely the best written character
which makes me imagine makes me think
that she probably did a lot of AB living
and like a lot of like kind of writing
her herself
it's the vibe that I got I had it like
an okay time in the theaters but this is
not one that I'm like raring to see
again like I I don't need to see this
ever again and I'll be fine I didn't
need to see this and I would have been
fine but I wasn't sitting there like
angry like I was in like Slenderman this
it was just like it's fine it's fine
it's fine there's a few fun scenes
there's this great scene Oh kind of
surrounding the word bitch and Melissa
McCarthy has this like fight scene with
like these Muppets you find out some
stuff about her and in this scene it's
it's fun and funny enough and I enjoyed
that one they should have gone further
with like the craziness that Muppet
surrounds humans and living with us and
integrated into our lives and it was
just kind of like oh it's just
supernormal spine instead of from ashes
to ashes they say - from fluff to fluff
it's so funny they should have pushed it
more I wrote
Oh with a lot of oohs the whole row of
oohs there is a scene and it is a scene
where the lead Muppet comes everywhere
just orgasms everywhere and listen I'm
all about it I'm here for Muppets
sexual health and exploration but it did
not land it was not funny it was so long
it was awkward is that what they were
going for were they're going for like an
awkward kind of kind of deal it was in
the trailer too watching the trailer I
was like engaged enough I was like oh
yeah that seems fun and then that scene
happens in the trailer and I'm just like
oh no yeah it kind of lost me there and
it totally lost me in the actual movie
too I don't know like I'm not like I'm
not a prude I enjoyed the occasional
like you know raunchy Joe or like fart
joke or something like that like I'm not
like above that type of humor
it babe it didn't land at all and most
of the comedy didn't last there were a
few fun moments but then overall the
audience I was with seemed to be
enjoying it about as much as I did which
was like it's fine I wrote Melissa
McCarthy cackles Joel McHale though so
you know there's some good in it all in
all though it was super lackluster I
have no interest in seeing it again it
was fine if you're a super big Muppets
fan and you also like orgasm jokes then
this is the movie for you I honestly I
was more engaged in the trailers than I
was in the entire film the film is
really short to one hour and 30 minutes
it's really short still like I likes oh
come on let's go the trailers though
assassination nation looks intense
and awesome and I'm all for it I
definitely want to see that bad times at
the El Royale is the best trailer I've
ever seen it was such a good trailer it
had me hooked from start to finish it
started off like very stylized and then
it goes into like this weird like kind
of horror thriller and just that actors
in oh my god I can't wait to see that
I've literally never heard about it
until I saw the trailer tonight and I
can't wait to see that's the nun
honestly the whole conjuring series is
just like right up my alley I really
enjoy it
I'm gonna be out of town for that so I
don't think it'll get a Tamra just saw
is pissing me off I'm pissed
and then peppermint with Jennifer Garner
who I haven't seen been like an action
star since like alias I think pretty
sure that was the last time she looks
badass
I wrote yeah it is yes bitch you get it
yes oh my god Jennifer Garner yes yes
then bitch again so this is very
exciting I think this episode of Tamra
just saw is like just as interesting as
the film and by that I mean not very I
don't know guys I wouldn't recommend
seeing it though there's not much coming
out this week so if you are somebody who
goes to the theater weekly I guess it's
like kind of your only option and it's
see much folks happening it's kind of a
slow couple weeks for a film honestly
everyone knew crazy rich Asians was
coming out they were like you know what
we'll just let them have all the
limelight cuz it's amazing should have
seen that again thank you so much for
watching next week I may be joined by
mr. Cody Meltzer
he's in town we'll see if it all works
out thank you again thank you for
watching this you got this bar I'll see
you guys next week
[Music]